en este vídeo les voy a presentar el
concepto de convolución una de las pocas
veces en la que los matemáticos nombran
algo parecido a lo que realmente hacen
pues de hecho se convulsionan las
funciones y en este vídeo no vamos a
entrar en detalle hacia el entendimiento
de la conducción ya que hay diferentes
formas de ver este concepto y sus
aplicaciones si ustedes van a estudiar
ingenierías de cualquier tipo verán la
convulsión en su forma discreta en su
forma continua en muchas formas
diferentes pero el objetivo de este
vídeo es que ustedes se familiaricen con
el concepto de convolución especialmente
en el contexto de la transformada de la
plaza entonces el teorema de la
conducción aunque bueno pensándolo bien
antes de entrar en el teorema vamos a
definir qué es convolución digamos que
yo tengo una función f
dt si yo con solución o f con g esto
significa que voy a tomar la conducción
fg todo esto va a ser una función de t y
hasta el momento nada de lo que he
escrito debe tener sentido para ustedes
he definido qué es lo que significa esto
esto es como en los exámenes en donde
les dicen un problema pero les definen
qué significan los términos que usan
aquí también yo tengo que definir de qué
se trata esto y tengo que definirlo de
una forma similar así que vamos a
deshacer
esto que escribí aquí y la definición de
la acumulación aunque existen varias
definiciones pero la que veremos
nosotros en el contexto que nos interesa
es la integral
de cero efe dt menos tal
efe dt - tau que está x gmt perdón
perdón por g de tal de lado con respecto
a está o quizás esto les parezca algo
bizarro de hacer y me pueden preguntar
bueno cómodo siquiera puedo calcular una
de estas cosas bueno para resolver sus
dudas vamos de hecho a calcular una
combo lución así que tenemos que
encontrar algunas funciones que sean
fáciles analíticamente de convolución ar
cosa que no es sencilla pero en que
tenemos que realizar varias identidades
trigonométricas para poder calcular
estos pero si yo dijera que ft si yo
definida a mí
efe dt que es igual al seno de t y
definiera coseno dt que lo escribo
naranjas como dt igual al coseno de t y
ahora vamos a convulsionar ambas
funciones
convolución df con g
y recordemos que esta va a ser una
función de t
va a ser igual
a esto nada más les voy a mostrar cómo
aplicarlo
la integral en púrpura de cervantes de
ft menos tal si ésta es mi ft entonces
va a ser seno de temenos estado x g de
tao si ese es mi gente que está o va a
ser coseno de eta o coseno de tao
de tao
así que esta es la integral y ahora
vamos a evaluarla y para eso tendremos
que usar trigonometría vamos a hacerlo y
pues vamos a aprovechar que esto va a
ser una muy buena revisión de nuestros
conceptos trigonométricos y también
nuestros conceptos de integración pero
bueno vamos a evaluarlo y quiero hacerlo
porque quiero mostrarles que esto no es
algo abstracto y lo primero que voy a
hacer bueno de hecho yo no sé cuál es la
anti derivada de esto aunque quizás nos
veríamos tentados al ver que hay un
coseno y un seno pero ésta está en
términos de temenos estado así que
permítanme reescribir y usar una
identidad trigonométricas seno de t -
tau
va a ser igual al seno de t
el seno de este x el coseno de tau menos
el seno de eta o multiplicado por el
coseno de t y de hecho existe un vídeo
donde yo explico todas estas identidades
trigonométricas también para repasar yo
misma de estos conceptos pero bueno
regresando al problema si hacemos esta
sustitución y esto lo van a encontrar en
los libros de cálculo y trigonometría en
donde se obtiene la convulsión de fg que
es igual
efe asterisco g es igual a la integral
de 0 a t
y en lugar de poner el seno de este
estado escribimos esta sustitución así
que escribo el seno de t por el coseno
de tau - el seno de estado por el coseno
de t
y todo esto se multiplica por el coche
no de tal
los senos de tal tienen que tener
cuidado de no confundir los estados con
las tes y todo esto
no perdón de tal justo lo que les estoy
diciendo no confundir te contaba ahora
vamos a distribuir este coseno de estado
en lo que se encuentra dentro de los
paréntesis que es lo que obtenemos efe
involucionado con g
es igual a la integral
de 0 a t
de ese no de 'the x coseno de estado
turco seno de estado así que nos queda
coseno cuadrado de tao
- escribamos primero el coseno dt ya que
estamos integrando con respecto a tau
así que escribo mi coseno de t primero
coseno de t x el seno de tao
por el consejo de estado
de tal
y ahora como estamos haciendo la
integración de dos cosas que se están
prestando vamos a volverlo dos
integrales separadas por lo que esto es
igual
a la integral de cero a t de seno dt
coseno cuadrado de tao
de tal - la integral de 0
de coseno dt seno de estado por seno de
eta o de tau vamos a tratar de
simplificar esto recuerden que estamos
integrando con respecto a town aquí me
equivoqué por eso les digo hay que ser
muy cuidadosos se integra con respecto a
tal así que todos estos que tienen
tiempo como el coseno dt
estas son constantes el seno de t
también es una constante y lo podemos
sacar de la integral
recordemos que integramos con respecto a
todo así que todo lo que no tiene estado
lo podemos sacar de la integral en este
caso el seno de t y el concierto de t
porque esto nos queda igual al seno de t
por la integral de 0
coseno cuadrado de estado de estado
y ahora menos
el seno de este
recordamos que esas son constantes por
la integral de 0 ante de seno de tal
por el costero de estado de estado
podemos ver que está anti derivada es
bastante directa podemos hacer una
sustitución que de hecho vamos a hacerla
aquí ya que es un problema complicado y
no queremos omitir ningún paso
si decimos que uno es igual al seno de
tal idea con respecto a tal va a ser
igual al coseno de tao o podemos
escribirlo como la deriva de déu es
igual al coseno
tal de cao y no se preocupen vamos a
cambiar esta sustitución antes de hacer
nuestra evaluación aquí en esta integral
pero esta es un poco más complicada no
sabemos cómo encontrar la anti derivada
de coseno al cuadrado de tau no es algo
obvio el resultado así que para resolver
esto tenemos que usar otras identidades
trigonométricas y en un vídeo expliqué
expliqué
el coseno
el coseno cuadrado de tal
y estudio se han dotado como un ejemplo
es igual a un medio x uno más el coseno
de dos tal
y de nuevo esa es una identidad
trigonométricas
y lo pueden encontrar en cualquier libro
de cálculo
para sustituir esto aquí sustituir esto
acá
y vamos a ver en qué se convierte en
nuestras integrales esta primera de acá
nos queda seno de t
por la integral de 0 a t
de todo esto de acá
incluso puedo quitar este un medio de la
integridad lo puedo sacar ponerlo aquí
un medio de seno de t por la integral de
cervantes de uno más coseno de dos
portado todo esto es con respecto a
estado de tal
esta es esta integral de aquí y tenemos
esta otra integral menos
coseno de t por la integral y bueno aquí
vamos a ser muy claros aquí es cuando
todo es igual a cero
hasta que todo es igual a ti desde que
todo es igual a cero hasta que todo es
igual a ti y esto vamos a sustituir lo
aquí vamos a poner acá la 1 y después
mostramos que de eeuu es igual al coseno
de tao the town
así que todo esto lo podemos sustituir
con d
esto de aquí arriba lo vamos a sustituir
con de 1
así que nos queda aquí uno de uno y
veamos si podemos hacer algo útil ahora
con esto hacemos espacio aquí la
integral de aquí la anti derivada de
esto es algo bastante directo de
resolver vamos a escribir aquí abajo
escribimos esta parte que está fuera de
la integral un medio de seno de t
por la anti derivada de esto
total más
la anti derivada de esto
va a ser un medio por el seno de 2 está
un medio por el seno de 2 tal también
podemos hacer una sustitución con no y
decir que hubiere igual a coseno de dos
estados y todo esto pero bueno creo que
ustedes pueden reconocer lo que se está
haciendo aquí
y si no me creen pueden hacer la
derivada de esto tomemos la derivada de
lo de dentro lo multiplicamos por lo de
fuera y luego hacemos la derivada de lo
de fuera que queda coseno de 2 está y
esto lo vamos a evaluar de 0 a t
y por otra parte tenemos al menos coseno
de t
la anti derivada de esto
vamos a hacer esto a un lado para que
quede claro la integral de un bebé es
algo relativamente fácil es un medio de
un cuadrada y bueno es un medio de un
cuadrada pero que es un a bueno pues
definimos que era igual a seno de estado
así que la anti derivada de todo esto y
acá un medio de igual cuadrada
reemplazamos la uv y nos queda
un medio de seno de tau o seno cuadrado
de estado y esto lo vamos a evaluar
de 0 a t y de hecho no era necesario que
hiciéramos esta sustitución de uva k
pudimos haber visto que bueno esto es
seno de todo esto es cosenos de eta o si
tengo una función y tengo su derivada
puedo tratar esta función como si
hubiera una equis aquí seno cuadrado de
tao entre dos que es exactamente lo que
tenemos aquí parece que ya estamos en la
recta final estamos realizando la
convulsión de seno de t con coseno de t
y obtenemos
un medio lleno de té
ahora si yo evalúa esto ente que voy a
obtener temas un medio del seno de dos
de que es cuando sustituyó la está o por
el valor de t y de esto tengo que restar
la sustitución cuando todo es igual a 0
- 0 - un medio de seno de 2 x 0 de cero
así que esta parte de aquí es todo esto
de acá
seno de 00 así que esto lo puedo quitar
esta primera integral me queda
un medio se nos dé te porte más un medio
de seno de 2 t
bueno ya resolvimos con una parte ahora
vamos a resolver esta otra parte
esta parte tenemos
menos
co seno de éste
y ahora vamos a evaluar todo esto cuando
todo es igual a ti un medio de seno
cuadrado dt menos esta expresión
evaluada cuando está o es igual a cero y
esto es cero queda menos cero hasta el
momento todo lo que hemos escrito se
simplifica como permítanme hacer toda
esta multiplicación y cambia de color
queda un medio
dt seno de t
acabo de multiplicar estos dos términos
más un cuarto
de seno dt por seno de 2 t
aquí tengo menos un medio
seno cuadrado de t por coseno de t acabo
de hacer esta multiplicación de este
lado también y bueno esta sería una
respuesta válida pero sospecho que lo
podemos simplificar todavía más
quizás usando más identidades
trigonométricas este por acá se ve listo
para simplificar se sabemos que el seno
de 2 t y eso es una identidad que pueden
encontrar en cualquier libro de
trigonometría es igual 2 por el seno de
t
por el coseno dt
podemos sustituir esto aquí y qué es lo
que nos queda
voy a desplazarme un poquito aquí hacia
abajo
tenemos que es un medio de t por seno de
t más un cuarto de seno de t
x esto de acá que vamos a sustituir por
2 seno dt coseno dt esto es solamente
una identidad trigonométricas y luego
tengo esta parte que es menos un medio
seno cuadrado de t coseno de t
nadie dijo que esto fuera a ser fácil
pero al menos espero que sea didáctico
para ustedes al menos les enseña que no
se memoriza en sus identidades
trigonométricas para nada y todo esto a
que se simplifica bueno primero vamos a
reescribir esta parte esto es igual a un
cuarto y bueno un cuarto por dos va a
ser un medio
un medio seno cuadrado de t que es
multiplicado es por esto por coseno dt y
esta parte de x menos un medio seno
cuadrado de tecos seno de t
afortunadamente para nosotros estas dos
se cancelan y bueno tenemos este término
en el frente un medio de ts no de té y
ahora esto se cancela con este otro
y todo lo que nos queda de todo este
problema tan denso es un medio
el seno de t finalmente acabamos de
encontrar que en la conducción y de
hecho permítanme escribir aquí los
resultados
que realmente me dan ganas de escribir
esto en piedra después de tanto trabajo
escribimos ft es igual a seno de t g dt
es igual a coseno de t
y acabamos de encontrar que la
conducción de las funciones f y g que
son funciones de t está definida como la
integral de cero a t df dt - tau por g
de tao betao y esto es igual aquí voy a
cambiar de color igual a la integral de
cero a t de seno
dt - estado por g de estado de estado
y todo este relajo esta convulsión
resulta ser igual a algo muy
satisfactorio todo esto es igual a un
medio de té por seno de t
y la razón por la que estuvimos haciendo
todo este desarrollo tan pesado haciendo
trabajar a nuestra mente recordando las
identidades sigo no métricas es
simplemente para demostrarles que esta
conducción pues si está algo compleja
pero realmente se puede obtener la
convulsión de dos funciones reales y
obtener otra función real
la conducción de xenón dt y coseno dt es
igual a un medio de tdt y bueno espero
que esto les haya dado un entendimiento
mejor sobre cómo podemos hacer el
cálculo de una convulsión